whilst playing video games we've become
attached to the characters we control
their reactions and emotions become our
reactions and emotions it's perfect
Ethan and by the end of the game we can
sometimes struggle to differentiate
between the gamer and the character when
Joel saves Ellie on an attack when girl
slays a mythical beast or when agent 47
performs the perfect hit we know it's
really us the gamers that have pulled
the character through the scenario sadly
though sometimes we fail and our heroes
take the fall for us this week's list is
dedicated to five heroes who didn't
quite make it to the end credits we want
potential spoilers for the following the
Bioshock series is renowned for late
game twists which made the gamer rethink
the whole experience BioShock Infinite
continues this trend by revealing that
the protagonist and the antagonist were
one in the same what makes this more
messed up is the way the situation is
rectified you are drowned you are
drowned by your own daughter this has to
be one of the most confusing plot twists
in gaming history
please akuto it
next up is the Call of Duty franchise
before Call of you to introduce
futuristic warfare
the series has loosely based in reality
the pinnacle of the franchise was
arguably the modern warfare trilogy
where we followed the enigmatic and
charismatic Captain Price and his band
of fearless SAS warriors
Sault McTavish was introduced in the
original modern warfare and quickly
became a fan favorite his bromance with
Captain Price became a staple of the
series until one night in Prague
after falling from a building he's
dragged to safety with his last breath
he passes on Intel to his best friend
before he succumbs to his injuries
rest in peace captain McTavish
so you have to go up now get off hey
I'm sorry
The Walking Dead comic book was given
extra life when the TV franchise
captivated audiences through the video
game version of the comic book we are
able to directly influence the storyline
but band of a zombie apocalypse
survivors over five episodes we took
control of Lane as he looked after
Clementine he was close to fulfilling
his mission until he's bitten and will
soon change into one of the undead his
parting gift to Clem was a gun and a
request to kill him in one of the most
impactful scenes in videogame history
Clementine does her duty me too
heavy rain blurred the boundaries
between cinema and gaming of its tale of
the origami killer you play as a number
of characters namely Ethan Paige Scott
and Jaden tasked with finding Ethan's
son who's been taken by this murderer if
you play particularly badly I'm a father
to all the characters meet a depressing
end scott falls into an industrial
grinder Jaden is stabbed to death Paige
is taken out by a madman and Ethan
probably the worst takes his own life
due to the guilt of the situation come
to think of it heavy rain was a terribly
depressing game my name's John Marston
Red Dead Redemption was a groundbreaking
game which took the systems found in GTA
4 and took them back in time about a
hundred years this was a time when
failing to complement another man's
Tabard would result in a tense duel to
the death luckily for us our hero is a
dab hand with a stick shooter good ol
John Marston
the game's narrative had players trying
to keep John out of trouble and to leave
his criminal past behind him the only
catch was if he wants to be left alone
to see upstairs on the ranch he must
first bring down his former gang of
Outlaws
so after way more than 20 hours of
making amends for past expressions you
finally reached the end of the game and
settle down with your wife and son only
for the government to change their minds
you have one final opportunity to take
down your enemies using the duel
mechanic
I was absolutely gutted like so many
others when John perished but rockstar
games had a little extra to keep the
Mastan storyline going fast-forward 10
years and you take control of Johnson
and Jack you can take revenge for your
father by hunting down
Edgar Ross the mastermind behind it all
and filling him full of lead betrayal
must not go unpunished
so that was our first list of video game
heroes who didn't quite make it to the
end of the game if you've enjoyed
wasting time with us please give us a
like and think about subscribing if you
have any ideas for future videos please
pop them in the comments below see you
next time
you